when it comes to holiday gift giving
food and wine gifts
seem to be just the right fit especially
when your name is on the wine glass okay
lifestyle expert amy sewell shares gift
shares
for every taste i'm amy sewell
when it comes to holiday gifts food is
always just the right fit
especially for people who might be
difficult to shop for if you're looking
for some ideas to suit any taste
i worked with several companies to put
together some ideas now omaha steaks
always has
fabulous holiday gift packages and this
year is no exception
this tasteful gift assortment includes
four each of their bacon wrap filet
mignon
top sirloin boneless pork chops boneless
chicken breasts
omaha steaks burgers and jumbo franks
you even get individual scalloped
potatoes for sides
and caramel apple tartlets for dessert
now this entire package is 179.99
and although there's still plenty of
time to order for holiday delivery
go ahead and order now so that you can
take advantage of standard shipping and
check this off your list you can order
this at omahasteaks.com
and you can pick up the same item in
your local omaha steak store
now it may be winter time but it's
always the perfect time of year to enjoy
that delicious year-round treat
ice cream and e-creamery has the perfect
gift for those with a sweet tooth
their santa sweet treat collection has
four pints of their
hand-churned holiday ice cream flavors
including chocolate cake with brownie
bites and fudge swirl
sea salt caramel brownie vanilla with
toffee crunch
and my personal favorite white chocolate
peppermint with chocolate flakes
this even includes a dozen of their
freshly baked cookies with these cute
holiday stickers
now in addition to their holiday
collections eat creamery will actually
let you customize your own ice cream
flavors
and the labels for those cartons
everything is packed and shipped with
dry ice
so it arrives in great condition and
ready for people to enjoy
the santa sweet treat collection is
74.99 plus shipping
and you can find this at ecreamery.com
personalized gifts are always popular
and personalizationmall.com is my go-to
place for that
they're a leading e-commerce provider of
personalized products
and offer thousands of items with a
broad range of innovative options
for the holidays i love these christmas
plaid wine glasses
these come in three different sizes you
have a stemless as well as red and white
wine glass
you can also choose from either red
green or mixed plaid
now these are festive for the holidays
but they're not specific for christmas
so
these are glasses that people can enjoy
any time of year
another thing i love about
personalization mall is that you choose
your product and personalization
and you can then see a rendering of
exactly what your design will look like
so you can make changes if needed
these classes start at 11.99 each and
you can find them at
personalizationmall.com
for more information about any of these
gifts and more holiday gift ideas
go to shopwithstyle.com happy holidays
happy holidays amy i love those wine
glasses that ice cream is really good
too by the way again
her website visit shopwithstyle.com